[Music]
guys make sure we're live on YouTube you
can't see it but they're just a bunch of
zoomed in Brad Pitt's did oh my god that
was a well guys guys
did you see what just happened
at the Oscars did you be whole now is
crazy yeah that was whoa that was nutty
we were like we were so surprised by
what happened I was like is this plan
but has the plague er like whoa this is
not planned yeah everybody looked like
they didn't quite know what to do like
that was uh that was like magic that was
like I feel like that's the best
possible thing at least right now why
because now they're both of those movies
are tied to a moment that's bigger than
the award itself like like this wasn't a
run-of-the-mill award except like they
got to basically give their acceptance
for the wall an award age for all
intents and purposes it feels like they
want and then with grace they were like
actually we [ __ ] up here you go and
now under both of those movies are
basically recognized at the same time
they could be or law like to be
perceived as the most viewed loser of
the Oscars like maybe they're like both
of them had it had a fair shot at
winning like I could have seen either of
those films
I guess that was a neck-and-neck race to
me man I mean law landlord did win a lot
of awards there it will hem points out
here because the thing is like this
didn't feel like it lost to me I just
feel like they thinks by some weird
coincidence they both kind of won like I
just can't believe the aw that would
happen at the Oscars you know that's
great weird vain Dunaway and and Warren
Beatty already looked a little out of it
what they were like doing it it seemed
like I was like maybe they're just old
but Faye Dunaway knows a little weird
and Warren Beatty just I haven't seen
moonlight so I can't really comment on
whether I thought it was best Fisher or
not but it seemed like I mean well I had
a lot of Oscar stuff written all over it
too as well as everything moonlight had
y'all for it but this is a controversial
Oscars in my opinion for an event that I
thought was rather boring to watch this
is still like one of them I think this
is a rather controversial Oscar because
people were upset when Mel Gibson Casey
Affleck getting nominated acts no Gerson
didn't win but Casey Affleck one that's
gonna have said a lot of people off in
the world just because he won and you
know they're all those many jokes about
it earlier but they're all those talks
about how like because black is weren't
nominated last year people are thinking
like other you and add a bunch now just
because before black well I hear these
are actually great in the performances
are amazing for the people who want
well there was it's more to them it's
not just like oh we're giving these
words more to more black people it's
like there are more move like in light
of there not being enough awards given
out you know to a diverse range of
people that cause people to stand up
basically go well there aren't that many
movies and then people started to make
more of those movies that we have a more
diverse range of voices in you know the
mainstream cinema marketplace now like
because of that I just don't get why
Warren Beatty had a card that said Emma
Stone Long Island on it like why were
they given that card is a mistake of
some kind or a weirdo and someone's
getting fired
weird [ __ ] jizz happen right now but it
was I don't know I thought it was kind
of beautiful Steve Harvey must feel so
relaxed two people already make a Steve
Harvey sense but there's I bet you Steve
Harvey is like thank God someone else
did it or something else in it because
now people won't just go remember that
Steve even then it's like bull to see
barbecue but well but man that's that is
nuts that was that's never happened at
the Oscars that was crazy
yeah dude MN Shyamalan's back this is
best twist since the sixth sense and I
think you know yeah not really be as his
three-peat to solidify him as a force to
be reckoned dude that was uh I was
[ __ ] crazy
I mean I'm so glad I'm a stone one
though yep we'll do a little recap we're
gonna be up early like literally three
minutes but yeah
like I'm so glad Emma Stone won because
I really wanted her to win I thought she
gave up there like Ryan Gosling not
winning as much as I loved Ryan Gosling
just seeing clips of like Manchester by
the sea I'm like Casey Alex you might
get a much more emotional don't you roll
is looking at clips of it and trailers
and stuff and but Emma Stone I felt
really deserved for that Damien Chazelle
winning I could totally see why that one
yeah you know I thought I was thinking
like maybe Mel Gibson had a chance I'm
ready yeah I thought so too I mean it
seems like they hate turns TV off Tommy
sorry Scott well it seemed like they at
least made a decent effort to spread
some of the awards around it wasn't like
we just he'd Awards on one thing
constantly and I'm trying to remember
where all the things at one word but you
know I yeah I thought the stuff that
woman was pretty appropriate there's
some stuff that you could argue you
could argue with but most things seemed
I wasn't super shocked by anything oh
well yeah none of the wards were
shocking everything was like yeah yeah
we kind of saw that coming there were a
lot of bad there was a lot of me going
cool like you know nice that this other
movie won you know at least a technical
Awards me yeah dude
so that was a crazy it was a rather
whirring Osterman and it didn't really
get excited until the best picture
wicker boom all I won't we're like yeah
okay yeah that make sense
and I was like told you John best movie
of the year
and then wouldn't that happen is
something I'll never forget experience
but we finally had a moment in Oscar
history we were like we're gonna never
gonna forget that yeah we're gonna be
like we were there we should watch that
live when it happened yeah some weird is
going down and yeah Wow yeah I still I
feel like I'm still processing this
moment this just happened well yeah I
mean let's look at some common stories
quick most darn it Todd I wanted a rival
to win man I like to rival line I don't
know what I mean it makes me feel sad
for the filmmakers because it does think
about it like you get up you're all up
on stage you don't give these acceptance
speeches you give like a full-on accept
but stage you got this hold on a sec man
you're you're you're like you got to put
yourself in that position of feeling
like you won and then suddenly find out
oh no
you you actually lost and you just put
yourself out there like you're this
winter and you feel so great about it
and it's but they handled it really well
like they handled it well like Georgia
that hurt feeling there somewhere true
yeah like I'm sure it's a bummer not
like I felt very happy to win and then
that got taken away yeah but nobody was
shitty about it like they they very
smoothly went into it I don't know I
feel like at that point like when that
kind of thing happens when somebody
[ __ ] up I'm like yeah it is a bummer
to lose definitely but at the same time
I feel like everybody on that stage was
a part of a of this kind of special
moment together and they're obviously
those are the two films kind of warring
at each other in that category there's
everyone's picking them apart in the you
know movie sphere arguing for and
against them like this way they're
they're both got on stage and got to say
some positive stuff together and became
part of this moment that's probably one
of more men
cool things that's happened on the
Oscars in a while so like yeah I do
think they it's got a suck not to win
but something special happen to
everybody anyway you know yeah I know
that's that's technically Graham I'm
talking about how they probably like I
can't imagine you just I can't imagine
someone just feeling like feeling the
euphoria and joy and the gratification
of winning the biggest award in movie
history yes then to go on live TV on
stage no not actually it's a bummer sure
you would I mean it would be it would be
bittersweet you know you'd be bummed out
but something else something cool happen
I guess I guess Chong's trying that
optimistic thing you know no I thought
it was still a special me because it
made me feel good for both of them like
like they both won to me just as a
viewer watching I was like oh I really
like lollol and a whole lot like I get
you know I was just like yeah Hollywood
does seem to love movies about Hollywood
but hey I loved it too so little yeah
what can I say about that and then yes
year doesn't make any sense
Trump is president Ben Affleck snot
directing the Batman
Warren Beatty [ __ ] up the Best Picture
Oscar I don't know I don't know if
somebody handed they were weird envelope
or yes suicides one of the capital
Suicide Squad water no hops and that was
like him that's crazy yeah that was
strange that was I mean like the good
like youth it was good makeup like it
was definitely good make it something
feels like it was a minor setup hey yeah
I can I can I can definitely if you told
me that somebody slipped it in there
like if it might not have been an
accident but I don't know who knew about
it you know I don't know if this is like
a high up thing or if this is like a
somebody just [ __ ] up you know yeah it
does seem it does seem suspect cuz this
is such a heated year like it's an
anxious time in the world the art
community is a part of that debate like
you know there's a lot of tense debate
around
the Oscars mean if they give the award
to who this movie of that movie so yeah
there's more of that surrounding this
Oscars than a lot of other ones in the
past so hey like something hinky happens
I'm sure there could be a design at work
I don't know well I guess the bottom
line is black people were very much
distributed against last year's Oscars
this year
black people owned the Oscars oh man the
black people were killing it killing it
this year me Oscars game unstoppable at
Davis Ella Davis yeah versus OJ no
moonlight the moonlight was it was a oj
made in America right
you know Tiger Dean what's up yeah the
guy cottonmouth and Luke Cage one you
ever moonlight [ __ ] moments of that
were cute
Denzel got to marry two people and yeah
boom I wins hell yeah
black people they are who I aspire to be
I mean I feel like we should just aspire
to be ourselves and be comfortable with
that baggage and be curious about each
other I don't like to narrow it down
make it easy one let's all just become
grey all right guys we're gonna call it
a night we just wanted to chime in real
fast you know Simon go live uncut
uncensored the raw [ __ ] thanks money
house for tuning in today see whether or
not we're wearing pants just got to take
her word for it but good luck I'm a
creative writing class bunny and elliya
scene yeah man you're Delia's scene said
it's like imagine someone giving you the
million dollar lotto ticket then your
dog eats the paper that's not the same
thing yeah it's exactly the same got the
same they've seen understand good movies
got recognized
same time okay okay John because like
for a minute there they did win we all
accepted that as true so they got to
give speeches as though they had won and
then something changed and then the guy
came back around and did a very smooth
and very graceful switcheroo and now
they're losers
[ __ ] it did the right thing and so like
that's even better had an opportunity to
be gracious and they [ __ ] took it
well that this is how I'm always gonna
remember La La Land it's the most
popular surfing out of love the most
popular loser of 27 to 16 love it but
but it's the love move because I'd have
loved they sacrifice and they said no
this is the right thing to do what we're
gonna do I guess that makes more sense
here it is a lot of these who dream it
is like lala land to give away their
Oscar Cydia stars are you shine just for
me stars are shining for like Warren
Beatty has officially redefined his
image boys back is gonna show up and
just like drop crazy ass truth flubs if
Warren Beatty runs out of career options
he can just do spoofs of himself and any
Adam Sandler comedy now oh boy alright
guys we'll take care thanks for stopping
by thanks for coming to say what's up
we're very tired it's a Sunday night
love y'all peace